tell me the third University have you
ever you had any bad reviews no they
make a man feel good Graham no I was in
a play I'd never ever been
professionally reviewed and in the paper
the next day was a British theatre
critic who said I was completely out of
place too young to rather and projecting
about as much masculinity as Graham
Norton fabulous is Loki Thank You Ian
budget apparently you originally
originally auditioned no offense is
meant by my incredulity he rats right
but you originally auditioned for Thor
yep Iain okay why why did you go with
this then her hair I think it was the
hair this is my brother from another
mother
Mendelson you have fan up at such
specific fan art it's a lot yeah it
doesn't all come for this one scene it
was at the first Thor movie with the
spirit rising yeah yes
desert there the scene in a first door
film where my I'm trying to attack so
Chris Hemsworth as Thor with this fear
and I jump in the air and he ducked he
dodges out the way and I bring the spear
down and it wedges itself into the floor
and Miley use the user to spin myself
around and kick him in the chest which
has been interpreted by fans as a
demonstration of my hidden talent at
pole down all dares yeah yeah no I
there's so much of this but this is just
one example of Loki really going for it
on the pole
is that Japanese party we're in the
middle in the pasture to India visit
there's an expedition to this cultural
landmark or the mariborkev by elephant
I'm delighted to reveal that I played
the front right leg of the elephant and
four of you to make the elephant that's
right yeah yeah I was sitting on you
he's sitting we're holding a table along
with a cushion on top of it and also
tablecloth to cover our faces because
with our bodies of the elephant yeah so
that's um that sounds awful accommodate
you know I think a lot of youngsters
they you know they Revere you so they
made it to the other thing you inspire
is impressions people doing impressions
well when people do impressions of you
is it like sort of nails on a chalkboard
or do you kind of enjoy it no I I kind
of enjoy it especially if they do it
well so no I great I love it
I only are no because because of any
Hiddleston is watching will know and Tom
Hiddleston does you know what ready love
it's always in your Canon it's a
expression of admiration just to be
clear so I do i do heard especially for
people that I admire and I said listen
to the mic I get the first time I did an
impression of anyone was aware of I was
just telling a story about Midnight in
Paris that Woody Allen film I was in and
how I never had the whole script and I
thought it was set in the 20s and I
turned up and I bonded that Owen Wilson
who didn't look like he was in the 20s
at all and and I said to him I said so
we haven't who you playing and I'm
playing a scott Fitzgerald and I know
Corey Stoll playing on his Hemingway and
we're all playing figures of history and
he went oh no no no no I'm from now I go
back into
that's a time machine it's kind of cool
and it's kind of woody and you just kind
of his kind of awesome I don't know I
mean I've done it I've been making the
impressions of my fellow Avengers and I
think everyone does an impression of
Christopher Walken because he's this is
such an easy kind of you know I feel
like what this show needs is more
cowbell depends on what you like me to
say basically there's no punctuation
anything that comes out of my mouth I
know whole pages of heat you surprised
me so I said this there's a scene in the
middle of the film which you'll be
familiar with you with that one graphics
don't need to explain it
[Laughter]
you're very good in the in the min of
the film which is because because Al
Pacino Robert De Niro sorry buddy oh I
bet they're separated like a great
thriller they're separated from for the
entire film and they meet twice once at
the end of once in the middle and it
takes place at a restaurant la it's a
great scene it's one of the great pieces
of screen acting you can have to watch
there it is it's a picture of it's like
it's a mutual recognition of each other
anyway so there's a bit where they have
like this sit and have coffee and had
tea and talk about stuff I'm going on I
apologize anyway so
Al Pacino at one point Albertina says
this he goes sir so we're sitting here
like a couple of regular fellows I mean
that you do what you do I do what I
gotta do if I'm there and I gotta put
you away I won't like it but if it's
between you and some poor bastard whose
wife is gonna turn into a widow brother
you are going down and then then I got a
cut and then Michael man cuts back to
the esteemed gentleman at the end of the
sofa what have you do got me boxed in
I'm not gonna put you down
we've been face to face yeah but I will
not hesitate not for a second that's my
is that when a Hiddleston's came from
from Loki III that's a whole other world
I don't know that you know all about the
Hazel's owner
they're very sweet mostly benign yeah
there's a few of them and then the
little stoners get a little bonus here
not me I don't know I've never that
something I'm not even put up
I don't put that out into your pardon
Express
I haven't extended that into me no it's
a generally you know that's Christian
believe I found eyes have lost two words
okay they're sweet and benign and
they've and their fans and and and yeah
I read unusually that's a factor you you
negotiated you lobbied for extra nudity
trying to sell the film love it remember
it was you know Gothic romance series
it's about sexuality it's about it has
to be sexy and there is a love scene in
the film thank you
gemma is like bored if Gambel get naked
man you lap will show the world your
bond and it was I was happy to do it we
discussed it often in these situations
the woman is more naked than the man and
we thought we would just redress the
balance can you go to this Robert DeNiro
[Laughter]
let me check in addition total so it
goes a little something like this
oh god here we go
she's a low home go home and I am a low
homes and blue so welcome
so for you have been on the show I feel
your pain bar
[Music]
you